c'est presque un monument historique qui
a été rayé de la carte cet après midi
une des barres de la cité des bosquets à
montfermeil a été détruite par implosion
symbole des ghettos des banlieues
elle avait pourtant été construite dans
les années 60 par le corbusier et à
l'époque c'était le symbole d'un certain
standing valérie war et patrie
goupilleau ont assisté à cette journée
très particulière
11h la barre numéro 2 des bosquets
s'apprête à vivre sa dernière journée
construit en 65 ses 146 appartement
était devenu trop vieux trop vétuste les
150 kilos d'explosifs sont en place en
moins de trois secondes c'est toute une
page de l'histoire du quartier qui va se
tourner vers le bas côté
quinze ans de ma vie j'ouvre la fenêtre
je regarde le bâtiment devant et puis
voilà
sorj d'ouvrir la fenêtre par nature à
avoir un petit peur ultime mesures de
sécurité dans le quartier et à 14h les
bâtiments alentour sont vides
plus de 2500 personnes ont été évacuées
invité à venir faire la fête sur le
stade municipal l'a fait car beaucoup
attendait cette démolition avec
impatience c'est l'opération symbole de
la volonté d'une population et de ses
élus de réhabiliter un site et surtout
de réhabiliter la dignité humaine il ya
beaucoup de bâtiments ils sont tous
regroupés donc il faut écarter payez pas
mal de problèmes et ça nos coeurs
c'était une même solution quoi
à
bien des verts je pense que ça c'est
triste quand même c'est une partie de
nous-mêmes qui part heureux un peu
triste les habitants pensent maintenant
à l'avenir un centre de loisirs devrait
remplacer le bâtiment première étape
d'un vaste projet urbain sur le bosquet
choisi comme l'un des dix sites
prioritaires de la politique de la ville